so the easiest shortcut for the brain to
seek truth is to look at someone who's
the most extreme version and then think
okay I don't have to apply a lot of
decision making filtering here because
now I can just absorb this because I can
just take this as fact if Warren Buffett
says this is how I should invest I feel
okay about that Source even if he's like
save your money spend less than you
earned dollar cost average into the s p
and don't buy gold he says that stuff
and you're like okay now the
stay-at-home teacher who's been saving
all of her money could say the exact
same thing but she just forgot to build
Berkshire Hathaway